歡迎回來趙花
我跟你講我們節目超級有誠意的
因為現在不是都在講成交量低嗎
沒錯
結果我們要增加來賓的人數
嘿嘿
多一點人來喊信心喊話
因為我們兩個人講可能不夠了
所以我們要讓大家知道
像現在比較沉淺
或者是有一些關卡卡在這邊的時候
往往醞釀的叫做什麼呢
什麼
黎明前的黑暗將來就會是大展光明
哦
突然好正效 好正能量
突然做一下效果
我們先來歡迎今天大來賓有兩位
第一位久久還很久沒有來了
但是每次觀眾看到她來都非常開心的
就是統一投顧的總經理PCB女王
廖婉婷 歡迎婉婷
嗨 趙華艾倫
突然卡住太久沒來了
太久沒來了
好 今天婉婷來要先幫我們
從產業面上打雞血啦
好嘞
因為婉婷前一陣子去看了
所以对于第四季到明年
今天我们不讲PCB
今天反而是要讲
看完半导体展之后
你有个感想
就是大封测时代要来临了
我们很需要你的加持
因为说实话
今年封测股的涨势
其实是没有其他的AI股来得多
然后一直在期待业绩赶快成长
那为什么看完半导体展之后
会觉得大封测时代要来临
另外当然是最近大家比较担心的
AI真的有降速降規的問題嗎
好 就是週末的時候
三大巨頭Athropeak開始講
他的員工就離職
然後就說再不管的話
AI會完蛋
然後他有可能在未來的某一天
殺死全人類
有10%的機率
10%還滿高的耶
對 然後所以Athropeak就開始講
就呼籲說要放慢發展的速度
好 但是這個是指的是AI的模型
它並不是表示AI的基建
其實模型跟基建是兩件事
而且模型它指的是非常前沿的
就是還在可能沙盒裡面測試的
並不是現在已經開始開賣的模型
那現在開賣的這些大圓模型
才是會跟基建比較直接的相關
所以我不會認為說
這個時間點AI的基建會放緩
只要AI基建沒有放緩
台灣的賣產值的業績就會繼續的水漲船高是對 所以我覺得這個恐慌有 因為大家搞不清楚所以需要我們來跟大家說清楚好,那大家的信心回來了之後這件事情立空就會結束
然後當然就是因為大家害怕
所以股市包括半導體廢半就跌了
然後所以川普跟華人勳
就通上了電話
然後告訴大家說
才不會了耶
AI算力本來就是未來的國力還有新石油
所以怎麼可能會停止
所以我們會有一個新石油
那你怎麼可能會停止
然後所以末日論就是一個騙局
對 所以大佬就跟你講說
不要太擔心
好 一個是美國的BOSS
一個是AI央行BOSS
沒錯
這個Enthropic跟OpenAI
回答的都是大股東
所以黃仁勳講話
他們應該要聽一下吧
對 是
對 所以基本上
我們認為不太會停手
對 所以大家不用那麼恐慌
可是你這個信心
需要被安撫一下
好 對
但是呢
我们这边要信心安抚
除了大佬的喊话
其实前一阵子的半导体展
展前轰轰烈烈
就展后大家安安静静
但是其实婉婷去看完之后
心里是激动的
对 我是觉得很棒的
那我觉得
我刚刚在照好来介绍的时候
我突然想到一个点
就是为什么今年风策股比较弱
因为今年是涨价年
今年是供需失衡的涨价年
对
但是今天的发展是它是盖房子
它房子现在里面越堆越多
越盖越大
但是呢
封册它并没有走向涨价这件事情
它在盖房子
可是它没有
这个房子没有在涨价
所以今年的投资主轴
它跑去了供需失衡的涨价股
导致这种盖房子越盖越大
但是加量不加价的
看起来股价比较弱
可是明年
我认为我自己会认为说
供需失衡这件事情会慢慢淡化
所以涨价的族群
它的光环可能会退掉
它也许不会跌
因為AI還在發展
他們公司的企業獲利還會在增長
可是價格驅動力會不見
好,那所以回來
大家就會看規格升級這個議題
好,那規格升級這個議題
就是晶片現在因為你功能要越來越多
你2.5D封裝變3D封裝、3.5D封裝
那這個就是有點像之前
就是記憶體跟主晶片放在一起
就COAX
然後未來就是COOP或CPU
你的OE光引擎會進來
然後再共同封裝所以它就會從2.5D往3.5D走好 然後所以當你要放越來越多東西的時候你的房子就要越蓋越大你才住得下這麼多的人好 所以你封裝就叫做蓋房子
把房子蓋起來
封裝的廠商訂單就會越來越多
好 然後可是今年比較辛苦的
就是我們之前還提到
熱月光 晶圓店
因為它資本支出先投
它要蓋房子 它必須要產能
它先投了 折舊出來
結果業績還不夠
然後就導致獲利成長性不夠強
那跟這個報價類股PK就輸了
所以封測廠商經驗獲利的YY
強度不夠大家就不愛
可是明年
我已經投完了
我接下來要開始創造收入
創造獲利
所以明年的重點就會再封測
對那我在半導體展看到就是
好多複雜的晶片
然後廠商在告訴你說
我在這裡面扮演什麼樣的角色
那像這個就是日月光展的
這個就是一個CPU的模型
然後這個就是所謂的
ESIC或GPU
然後這就是記憶體堆疊
這個就是所謂的2.5D封裝
然後在旁邊這個放的就是OE引擎
然後這樣一大顆
就是一個非常大的晶片
以前晶片只有這樣一顆
現在晶片這麼大顆
對 所以這個就是我當初在講
為什麼載版用量會增加的關鍵
好 然後這個也是
其實就是堆疊式封裝
所以你就會知道說
要這樣封裝
除了先進製程很強
然後再來就是大晶片
我封裝
大晶片
對 大晶片架構
所以我把它濃縮叫大封測
喔
好 大晶片
對 晶片越來越大
然後封裝的需求才能消耗
然後測試時間要變長
所以大封測
然後相關的材料設備股都會收回
好 然後所以我在現場
我也看到也有封測
還有測試的探針卡啦
還有這個測試底座啦
所以我們從就是
ProCart 探針卡
然後到這個測試基座的隱威
然後到這個SLT
還有這個Final Test
就是晶片測試
好 這些就是過去我們講
隱微旺系
好 然後跟這個老化測試
就是一樣就是金測
好 這些就是測試設備
然後呢 晶圓測試的部分
主要在COAS
它就會是台積電跟日月光座
然後晶片測試的話
就是那個晶圓電
好 所以日月光晶圓電
然後跟我們剛剛講的
金測 隱微 望系都會是有關係 跟晶片有關然後另外就是光的部分因為光OE引擎要進來然後所以現在設備廠商積極的在做這個光晶片的測試那它總共有四個步驟
然後第二個步驟跟第三個步驟最難做
所以這個有點卡關
讓OE引擎稍微比較慢的原因
可是就是因為卡關
所以它是更重要的
對 所以我這邊就幫大家整理了一下
今年跟明年的獲利
然後就可以看到很明顯的
就是有一些獲利的成長性很強
對 然後題材性在這邊
好 然後本一筆的部分
其實為什麼今年不漲
因為今年其實初
大家就知道大晶片概念
所以股價漲超多
去年底到今年漲很多
所以PE本來拉太高
但是因為最近休息了
所以反而你現在往時間點
多過了一年之後
你會發現它PE掉下來了
對 然後明後年大風測
獲利成長性夠高
PE又沒有很高的時候
我覺得這個族群就會是
今年底往明年
很好的佈局的產業
好 因為像尹唯曾經是萬元股
沒錯
结果现在已经掉到6000块了
虽然是高价股
但回挡幅度非常深
事实上如果明年能够呼应它
可能有高达这个
70几%的年增率的话
它搞不好又可以重新回到
一个成长的轨道上
是这样看
日月光跟晶圆店就是相对比较
牛皮比较委屈的
可是因为PE很低
对
所以非常安全
好 所以要成长有成早
要安全有安全
好 那我们就来看一下
日月光真的横盘整理
晶圆店也很多人
就是投诉说
到底为什么
它不是资本支出
已经创下令年新高
怎么还没有涨这样子
对 因为它
其实去年涨非常多
但是今年就受到
它的资本支出
所以导致折旧增加太多了
可是这些折旧
对明年就是好事
因为我的业绩
就可以开始创造收入
是 好
所以这个是安全组
对 就是风色双雄
这个就是活泼组
但是潜力无穷
对 那像今天雍智
雍智就涨停
对 因为它就是有
透过那个风格
然后拿到
有机会切进联发科
然后因为联发科现在就是
大家很关注它Google订单
所以就会觉得它未来成长性会有机会
然后另外旺系的部分的话
其实大家期待很高
可是因为它最近那个之前的座谈会
讲第三季的展望
讲得稍微比较保守
所以股价就相对比较弱
可是9月如果出来优于公司奖
大家就会认为说
公司可能是过度保守
那未来的期待还是很高的时候
可能反而股价就会在那个时间点动
好 就是很谢谢婉妮
跟我們分享了看完半導體賽以後
迎接所謂的大風測試代表
謝謝妳
好 謝謝